justin timberlake breaks his silence
with an apology to britney spears
after coming under fire for the way he
handled their split
in the early 2000s oh and while he's at
it
he's saying he's sorry to janet jackson
too the recent backlash stems from the
new york times presents framing britney
spears documentary that premiered
last week throughout the unauthorized
project footage shows
spears being put in the hot seat and
questioned about her role in her highly
publicized breakup with timberlake
he's gone on television and pretty much
said
you broke his heart you did something
that caused him so much pain
so much suffering what did you do
at the time timberlake was seemingly
glorified
and had this to say in a new york radio
interview when he was asked if he had
ever had sex with spears
who had previously publicly declared she
was saving herself for
marriage yes or no oh man come on man
okay i did it many viewers reacted on
social media after watching the doc
with several arguing that timberlake was
to blame for the media's negative
portrayal of the pop star
after their split while others brought
up his behavior towards janet jackson
after the infamous wardrobe malfunction
that occurred during their super bowl
halftime performance in 2004
in a statement posted to timberlake's
instagram on friday
the singer said that he's seen the
messages tags comments and concerns
and he is deeply sorry quote i
understand that i fell
short in these moments and in many
others and benefited from a system that
condones misogyny
and racism i specifically want to
apologize to britney spears and janet
jackson both
individually because i care for and
respect these women
and i know i failed justin added that he
doesn't want to ever benefit from others
being
pulled down again quote i want to take
accountability for my own missteps in
all of this as well as be a part of a
world that uplifts
and supports i care deeply about the
well-being of the people i love
and have loved i can do better and i
will do better
e.t has reached out to spears and
jackson for comment
as for the baby one more time singer a
source told e.t
earlier this week that she is aware of
the documentary but hasn't watched it
and e.t source added that spears has
no interest in getting involved with any
details being discussed about her past
relationship with justin timberlake
she wouldn't want her fans to speak
negatively about him because she has the
utmost respect for both justin
and his wife jessica beale